[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour en ce moment j'essaie d'adopter
un collapse haut mais qu'est ce que
c'est un ou une collab saut c'est une
personne qui s'intéresse à
l'effondrement locale et globale de
notre civilisation alors un rendez vous
galant entre deux collapse au je peux
vous dire c'est pas banal
ils partagent une lucidité qui les fait
parfois taxé de catastrophistes la
semaine dernière j'ai un premier rendez
vous une question se pose rapidement et
toi comment tu es venu à l'effondrement
c'est plutôt une bonne question je crois
que ça m'a pris du temps
ça m'a pris du temps parce que je suis
né au collapse ou et pour être tout à
fait honnête je pense que ma
compréhension de l'effondrement elle est
possible aujourd'hui parce que j'ai vécu
en 2015 un effondrement intérieur 2015 a
vraiment été une année de crise pour moi
il est d'abord les attentats de charlie
hebdo à ce moment là je travaille à la
télévision française comme journaliste
plateau je prépare l'émission
deux jours après les attentats double
prise d'otage dans une imprimerie de
dammartin et à l'hyper cacher à paris je
passe des heures
hébétée devant mon écran à regarder
défiler les mêmes images en boucle sans
qu'on ne sache rien cette journée me
paraît complètement surréaliste quand le
direct commence le deuxième assaut vient
d'être donné l'émission ne se passe pas
trop mal
l'animatrice gère mieux que moi la
situation clap de fin
je me sens vidé 2015 c'est aussi l'année
de la coop 21 la conférence de paris sur
le climat je quitte les plateaux de c
dans l'air pour une association clé ce
toubib et je plonge dans les affres du
changement climatique
je rencontre des dizaines de passionnés
inquiets qu'ils n'ont qu'une obsession
informer les citoyens est limité quand
c'est possible
lacasse environnementale en parallèle
chez moi c'est pas vraiment la joie mon
couple bas de laine c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire je rentre de ces journées
intenses et je trouve mon amoureux
devant ces jeux vidéo
chacun ses écrans pas les mêmes chacun
sa réalité pas la même j'ai l'impression
d'être dans deux mondes parallèles
d'un côté cette bulle de l'ain team
devenu morne et triste
de l'autre le bouillonnement des
initiatives qui veulent changer les
choses
sans nier le constat le 13 novembre
on ne réunit en équipe quinze jours
avant la coop 21 quand la poche de l'un
d'eux nous vibre une notification puis
deux puis plein on allume la télé et on
découvre l'horreur des attentats du
bataclan et là je ressens la même
fêlures qu'au moment de charlie hebdo
tout le monde part je reste j'habite
loin et les larmes coulent sur mes joues
toute la nuit
le lendemain
je rentre chez moi et je retrouve mon
amoureux devant ces jeux vidéo
indifférent même à ma détresse
la coop 21 commence sur les chapeaux de
roue je me sens loin très loin de chez
moi mon amoureux vient me rendre visite
je suis mal à l'aise le voile se déchire
et je ne peux plus le recoudre
c'est décidé je m'en vais après ça c'est
un peu le big bang
je n'ai plus d'amoureux plus de travail
plus d'appartements mon retour vers le
futur à moi c'est plutôt riquet marty
une série d'animations parodique riquet
marti voyages pas à travers le temps
mais dans des univers parallèles
complètement loufoque cynique aligné
avec ce que je vis je me lance en
indépendante
je n'ai plus envie pour un temps de
rester salarié jacques en panne dans
leur communication des porteurs de
projets engagés et puis je commence une
enquête aussi bonheur des zèbres zèbres
c'est le petit nom qu'une psychologue
française donne à ce qu'on appelle des
surdoué ou les personnes à haut
potentiel ce qui m'intéresse faire des
portraits d'adultes qui se reconnaissent
plus ou moins dans ces catégories et qui
les questionne chercheurs artistes
entrepreneurs
il me confie ce qui les rend heureux ou
malheureux y les causes qui leur sont
chères
le projet grandit la communauté aussi
j'organise des événements à paris à
bruxelles à lille ou à nantes et je
rends compte de plus en plus de gens qui
s'intéressent de près à cette question
de l'effondrement
alors je creuse
est ce que je découvre en creusant c'est
une réalité sidérante
une réalité qui dépasse l'entendement de
l'esprit humain
ce sont les spécialistes qui le disent
tous les jours vous entendez des
informations alarmantes sur le
changement climatique ou l'effondrement
de la biodiversité
vous voyez des images des conflits de la
montée du populisme aux quatre coins du
monde
vous voyez les inégalités se creusent et
dans les lucarnes de vos télés vous
comprenez mais vous ne l'appréhendé pas
vous ne riez pas tous ces faits ceux qui
s'intéressent à l'effondrement les relis
ce qui les vaut souvent de leur vaut
souvent de passer pour des cassandres ou
leur cause bien des soucis car comme me
le dit souvent un ami l'effondrement ce
n'est pas seulement un nouveau récit
efficace pour marquer les esprits c'est
une réalité déjà pour des millions de
gens à l'autre bout de la planète où
tout près d'ici
descola pso que je rencontre par au
bonheur des zèbres ou par les groupes en
ligne se pose pas mal de questions
ils se sentent seuls et se sentent
parfois désespérée faut-il agir et
comment ne rien faire faut-il même
accéléré l'effondrement
ils savent que ce qui est en jeu c'est
la survie de milliards d'êtres vivants
dans un futur plus ou moins proche et
que c'est l'ensemble du système qu'il
faut attaquer
le vieux monde se meurt le nouveau monde
tarder à apparaître et dans ce clair
obscur surgissent les monstres disait
antonio gramsci les colobes ce qui
m'entoure sont attentifs à ces dérives
messianique populiste qui peuvent
accompagner cette prise de conscience on
se dit que l'apocalypse est proche alors
on cherche des nouveaux prophètes pour
apaiser ses angoisses
on nous promet qu'on peut s'en tirer un
coup de start-up verte qui réinventera
la croissance ou ont surinvesti la
spiritualité comme seule voie de salut
d'autres se revendique survivalistes et
peuvent tenir des propos carrément
fascisant la vie personnelle est aussi
chambouler on supporte de moins en moins
les incohérences surtout les siennes on
parle de dissonance cognitive pour
désigner ces incohérences qui sont
tellement fortes qu'elles créent des
tensions à l'intérieur de nous certains
décident de tout plaquer pour aller
vivre à la campagne et cherche la plus
grande autonomie possible beaucoup
change de boulot pas ce qui leur paraît
absurde et arrête de prendre l'avion qui
plombent leur bilan carbone
tous réinventent leur quotidien pour
être plus aligné avec ce qui leur paraît
essentiel réduire leur impact négatif
donner du sens à leur vie
arrêter de se voiler la face l'intimité
en prend un coup elle aussi comment
faire couple quand la réalité nous
désabusé est ce qu'on décide de faire
des enfants dans un monde qui s'effondre
certains n'en veulent pas mais
comprennent ceux qui en ont ceux qui en
on se demande comment les éduquer de
manière réaliste
et responsable comme cet ami dont la
fille de 9 ans investit le club nature
de sa ville un des seuls endroits où
elles se trouvent des bons copains
reconnaître qu'on est tout près de la
fin d'un monde
c'est un grand pas parce qu'une fois
déchiré le voile qu'on ne peut plus
recoudre on fait quoi on entame sa
propre transition
on essaie de se relier à la nature aux
autres à soi même
le tissage de liens
c'est ça qu'on a perdu c'est ça qui nous
manque ça ne peut pas suffire mais on ne
peut commencer que par là le mois
prochain
je pars m'installer à bruxelles pour
lancer un projet qui n'aurait pas vu le
jour sans au bonheur des zèbres une
nouvelle page blanche
un nouvel appartement un nouveau boulot
j'ai toujours pas d'amoureux mais je
m'en fais pas je me suis trouvé moi je
n'aurais jamais pensé que je me
retrouverais devant vous aujourd'hui à
partager ses réflexions
quand j'étais dans le creux de la vague
il ya trois ans pourtant j'ai fait le
choix de ne pas renoncer d'assumer ma
vulnérabilité de profiter de chaque
rayon de lumière sans nier mais par
dhombres de créer des espaces pour que
mes amis collapse aux zèbres atypique et
moi nous puissions être seul ensemble
parce que dans ce monde mouvant et
incertain nous n'avons pas d'autre choix
que de trouver notre propre voie merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]